for centuries the turkana people of
rural Kenya lived in harmony with the
Earth
but the once Lush landscape has turned
to dry desert due to climate change the
impact is causing a conflict with the
neighboring community over dwindling
natural resources
viewers get a glimpse of it in a new
documentary called between the reins a
visually stunning and up-close look at a
turkana community at risk the film was a
collaboration between an American and
Kenyan filmmaker it took them several
months to gain the trust of the turkana
people we have to make sure after
getting the blessings from the elders we
also got acceptance to these houses as
well because we wanted to be
collaboration between us and then we
didn't want
since I come from a different tribe I
didn't want to be like I'm telling their
story I wanted the story to come from
them it took the filmmakers over four
years to complete the documentary they
had hundreds of hours of footage but in
the end between the rains made its World
premiere here in New York at the Tribeca
Festival
[Music]
the main character being a Shepherd boy
named colay viewers follow him as he
struggles with inner conflicts from
pressures from Elders to become a tribal
Warrior all while living in a prolonged
drought what we did in this film and
what kolei
in his path offered us was always the
ability to bring it back into a internal
story trying to follow this boy as he is
trying to find a place within a culture
in a community that is eroding and has
become a casualty to climate change this
complex character-driven film a rare
chance to see the effects of climate
change on a vulnerable yet strong people
Gabriel ozando Al Jazeera New York